hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to among the sleep
there is a strange noise coming from
over there
obviously I'm clicking this game up
again from last time I played it last
night I don't know what's happening over
here but I'm gonna find out what it is
what the hell is that okay don't know
what's happening over there something Oh
something trying to get out of there
it's something what is hitting there is
a piano ramming that thing it's a great
that I could normally climb through I'm
just wondering what the hell it is what
are you I know what you are but I'm
gonna forget about you and I'm gonna go
over here and try to outlive this land
of nightmares that constantly wants to
kill babies anyway I don't know if that
lady from the last level is gonna be
over here but I have some theories about
who she is now she's obviously related
to this kid in some way and I don't know
why but it seems like I'm looking for my
mommy and yet something here is not
right
maybe my mommy is not who I think she is
maybe it's all figment of my imagination
in the darkness of this child extended
okay okay
damn Jax for everywhere hatboxes and all
this douchiness you know somebody be
banging
hmm what are you I don't know what you
is what the hell is that oh god where am
I going why is it thrusting it's the
eternal burning question in my mind
something I ask all the time why is it
thrusting why okay here we go
okie dokie let's try not to tie this
early in the game I am just a little kid
but I deserve no mercy
obviously I've done some terrible things
in my life okay
thrusting is good okay alrighty then hey
what's over there oh I can't go over
that way that way leads to death so I
think I'll go this way
I think I remember seeing this level in
the developer thing they were actually
building this level as they were or they
made a video of them building this level
to showcase how it works where does this
go oh god sorry thinking around that I
need like crawl again there you go I'm
gonna assume no so I'm gonna just keep
going up the grandfather clock anyway
what I was saying about the lady before
that lady in the other area I don't know
if she's related to me somehow not
directly anyway because the paintings
actually had it the paintings actually
had a daughter in the pictures I think
who's in there ooh I hear creepy crawly
noises I'm gonna go in there stop it
Jesus get on the bag get out of my way
bag I need to get in here
can't get up jump hop hop of your little
tiny feet hop okay
terrible mistake I didn't want to
disturb you but I'm in anyway who's in
here who the hell do you think you are
huh
[Music]
that's a music box from before what do I
do about that
what bad Lola boy why is it bad why did
I give an achievement for that okay whoa
okay I thought thinking oh I thought
something bad was actually gonna happen
to me like death why is there an ace of
spades on the ground there good I'm glad
oh nevermind what's why me don't like
this game messing with me it decides
that he needs to mess with the likes of
me
who is too strong and brave and handsome
of a child
man baby to be boggy Kyle you can't say
I didn't see that I'm coming for you hi
hi you [ __ ] who do you think you are
glowing your eyes at me so you dare oh
hi are you alright
come back here eyeballs Hey look at you
loo okay fine you go run away who's that
on the ceiling why does that bicycle'
upside down what does that eyes over
there or is everyone just being a giant
bubble blowing baby and they don't want
to face the likes of me okay there was
nothing over here
never mind I'll carry on I'm just
wasting time at this point this is
obviously the last area from the memory
that I need so I need to find a way to
go and get whatever I do need hello lamp
can I crawl in here
can but why why I'm in here why is that
shaking what's the point of that I don't
know let me out
like to carry on with my mission
whatever that may be
there's something in these why did I why
was I able to find a bad lullaby and why
why why whoa
hello was that nothing what is that can
I go through there no yes
I don't know get out of my way you
briefcase [ __ ] okay I can okay so
that's a lie
there's two options here got the purple
door over yonder way that leads to
confined space and I'm gonna look at
come on hop up what do we got here big
shadow monster that's not quite like the
lady someone was scribbling away over
there so oh my gos iffy dude out fast on
my knees okay Michael I wasn't crawling
this fast before I swear I was not did I
just fall and break my anybody bones
sorry hi how'd you going how you doing
I'm hugging my teddy bear am i evil evil
teddy bear very tight anybody want to
mess with me what's in here hello who's
there
okay there's a lot of doors that just
lead backwards why is this door marked
by a big shadow answer is there a big
shadow monster behind this door is
anybody home anybody want a baby friend
no you do not you garments stop that why
are there so many coats I mean obviously
these things are what would scare a
little kid maybe scare a full-grown man
is
but I mean so sometime maybe I hear
noises surrounding me I don't like it
very much
ah someone dancing with another's I
gonna have to have dances boys can I get
up
okay I can't get up get up get up oh god
I fell okay mother panicked a bit Bob I
couldn't have my teddy bear what is that
over there
blimp hot air balloon model why is that
in a strange language I mean I guess to
a kid he wouldn't be able to do I her
are people talking over there how you
bad-mouthing me over there sorry
what okay thank you
oh go this way but because I chose it
and not because you made me
okay bloody baby clothes good big
glowing door also good all these things
are good don't know why your eyes this
one covered in blood hello sorry do I
need to knock something down
do I need to hit something hi honey
so it's a puzzle and I got a lot of
objects that I might be able to throw
some things high up so I got to figure
out a way to get down is that what
you're saying there you say to me oh
wait a minute
it just told me that I need to throw
stuff so yeah how about that glowy thing
okay sorry about the [ __ ] thrower
everybody I'm just a two-year-old there
we go
Oh someone didn't like that
sorry pick it up okay cool cool I'm out
I'm out I'm out here who says something
by me I thought that might have been
some behind me okay cool
close that door forever and hopeful
nightmare soon ah follow me what is that
one thing about this game that I really
really like is that it's um be on
account effect sings are very good very
good I mean they always sound like
they're directly behind me I do now like
this but I'm a brave man and you guys
want to see this story so I'm gonna
tough through it you need to go find the
star key no yes does that input in here
I've been hearing that sound for a while
oh where you been trying to survive
death wait a minute isn't that the
thrust II do dad this is all it's a
different thrust you do that I get to
[Music]
maybe I don't know don't ask me how am I
supposed to know
did that do the job okay
[Music]
so wouldn't sure what am I supposed to
do
I'd like some answers tonight questions
I'm just a baby
okay so I'm assuming I need to either
crawl through this hole can I crawl
through there damn it I can't I gotta go
this way I guess
come on hop up going on a little ride
little venture exploring the area who
knows what destiny demon Zowie
goddamnit I say bastard big demons way
too much who knows what undulating I
can't think of anything there what about
those things over there do I need to do
anything about that how the hell am I
gonna get this go sorry what do I need
to do to make it go I'm a beer a while
guys I don't know what I'm doing why am
i bouncing so much what is going on I do
not know can I go through here okay
bouncing bouncing baby baby bounce
bounce
okay still bouncing why jeez baby stop
bouncing double J alright so I had to
load back from another save point
because I think something went seriously
wrong even when I died the same sound
kept looping over and over again and
something seemed very bugged with a
bouncing I don't know what's your sound
buddy were you doing I need to figure
this out it's a puzzle
Oh Jared um I'm just a baby with the IQ
of a genius okay you see now it's doing
the pump II do but it's now bumpy
doo-doo on that she now is eating a box
and it wasn't before so there was a bug
they see now it's going backwards afford
it wasn't doing that before and now it
is so that was a bug that was bug it was
not my fault I was not breaking it in
any way on my own volition but it was
just breaking by itself I did not break
it it was not my fault everybody I am
not to blame here this is the game's
fault and most likely this baby's fault
I would blame the baby I would really
blame the baby yes it is how strange
that it is stuck well let me just get
that out of the way for you no no no
almost let go of it let go of it I'm a
baby but I'm various push there we go
okay that was supposed to happen
it was the elbows to break but I got it
this time I am in it to win it because
I'm super smart but she is very
before I would be more scared of it but
it did so here I go I am so enough
gloating about the game breaking let's
just keep the flow going here oh hey
Pope teach puppy come on get up on the
thing
Thank You kid come on we got time to
make up because you were breaking yep
good job kid now don't be bouncing over
here make your way over nice and calmly
Oh got it now we're looking for a star
gonna be a star kid gonna show them all
what you can do you gotta show them the
bright lights inside your soul yeah show
me true heart
okay what are we looking for are we
looking for a star we can knock down
lows down there death probably in here
no okay someplace we going come on let's
crawl into the dark and close named Earl
and I'm sure that nothing bad will
happen to me what bad could happen I'm
in the most capable hands of this teddy
bear that looks like somebody falling on
the ground in pukey why is somebody
falling on the ground and puking good
question where the hell am I now do I
want to fall down there here I go this
is a mistake wasn't it Oh No
I'm dead what the hell happened oh god
damn it dingus damn it post okay try
this again
what's that being an idiot hello balls
thank you for falling upon me what do I
need you for I don't see anything I need
to knock down oh my god I was way down
there I went through there but I went
through that what I came out up there
that's so weird but I don't know why I
need those balls for anything let's just
go through here hey wait a minute I'm
back home oh I need to take one of those
balls that I need to throw them up at
the bottle up hey honor
Oh God you run so slow with this dang
bear just get gone
get the ball throw it at the battle and
carry on your merry way wait a minute
that's not a bottle well that is a
bottle okay okay you are a wimpy wimpy
baby come on give it some moans okay
that was the one being slow I've ever
seen in my life that must be either
heavy heavy balls or you're just running
on a steam little kid how about you pick
up the pace cuz we got to conquer some
dark horrors here not horrors but
horrors all right how do we get a pie
okay that's how god I gotta go in it to
win it
jump up climb up higher how about an
orange or an apple can make it up there
oh wow okay you could have done that a
little bit better good
I will assist you by vacating the
premises i evacuate with your star wait
a minute this city right it's not where
I [ __ ] what's going on here this isn't
where I came out wait a minute what who
the why the how the oh I'm saving now
why was I not supposed to go this way
which way did you want me to go doing it
I don't know what you wanted from me oh
I get it I can't go back this way
because you cut it off what the hell
happened there okay
so I get it I get it I get what you want
me to do I think I do anyway not exactly
under percent is saving again can I
please get up get up up up Oh unless I
need to go under it here's what I need
to do now this is definitely the level
of they showed off okay did not mean to
stand up okay where do I go
can't see anything what am i doing climb
up
let me doing where am I going what am i
doing what we're doing what am i doing
where am I going why am i trapped under
here why did I need to crawl under I
don't think I didn't need unless they
needed to get this bucket and then I
used a bucket to get up hi I'm a genius
I'm a genius baby I'm a genius man baby
hop up here puppet online up on it
haha oh now you're gonna hop up okay now
that I've accomplished the incredible
task of hopping up I'm asking to stop
this episode here this has been rife
with troubles I don't know why but I'm
having a lot of trouble with it this
episode it's not entirely my fault not
entirely some of it does me to blame but
either way I will continue this in the
next episode I don't know how many are
left but I feel like we're approaching
your conclusion so anyway thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation with more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video a tape recorder attached
under the plate okie dokie